ein thema zum schluss noch das uns heute
auch noch bewegt hat ist nämlich wieder
turniers wir haben hier vor drei wochen
gesessen unter anderem ralf stegner mit
ihrem bundesarbeitsminister mit hubertus
heil und er hat gesagt mensch natürlich
ist der muss im zweifel dafür haften für
das ganze für die ganzen corona kosten
dort in der region
und jetzt hören wir der turniers will
das gegenteil der benehme mich
steuerhilfen haben im zweifel weil er
natürlich ganz enorme ausfälle da hat im
moment corona bedingt das klingt nach
einem ziemlichen unterschied innerhalb
von drei wochen von haften bis zur
staats kohle
also ich finde es skandalös ehrlich
gesagt was der trainer ist da macht es
in seinem konzern gibt es unmögliche
bedingungen was aber ist ein
wohnbedingungen angeht da wird richtig
findet sich ja ausbeutung statt
er hat eine menge damit zu tun dass wir
da so einen corona hotspot auch hatten
und so jemand braucht nicht starte hilfe
durch steuergelder sondern sollte ja zur
verantwortung gezogen werden da kommt
irgendwann mal staatliche kostenlos
das sagen sie man sich herr goldmann war
gar nicht nachgewiesen werden was
rechtlich falsch gemacht hat deswegen
günther oettinger auch an sie noch mal
infrage
bevor ich gehe zu machen die gesetze
nicht beachtet werden das konnte man
schon sehen die gesetze werden
missachtet dort ist ja gar keine frage
und dem muss nachgegangen werden mit
aller konsequenz und ich finde das
unverschämt die steuerzahlerinnen
steuerzahler da heran ziehen zu wollen
dafür